في ملف حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا نقلت وكاله
تاسع عن القوات المواليه لروسيا في اقليم
دونيتك الاوكراني قولها انها تحاصر مدينه
باخموت مضيفه انها ستبدا قريبا ضرب اهداف
في الجانب الغربي من المدينه وان السيطره
على باخمت مساله وقت وفي كييف قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها تواصل صدى
الهجمات الروسيه بشكل رئيسي في اتجاهات
وكوبيانس
واشارت الاركان الاوكرانيه في بيانها
الصباحي الى ان قواتها شنت 27 غاره على
مناطق تمركز القوات الروسيه ومعداتها
العسكريه وانظمه الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات وكما اعلنت انها اسقطت مقاتل
روسيه واربع طائرات بدون طيار واضافت ان
القوات الروسيه تشنت خلال الساعات الماضيه
10 ضربات صاروخيه و25 غاره جويه على مناطق
متفرقه في لوغانسك ودونيسك وخاركيف
وزباروجيا كما نفذت 62 طلقه من انظمه
اطلاق الصواريخ ما ادى الى سقوط قتلى وجرح
ى من السكان المدنيين